تمتد مقبرة القرم القديمة عبر
التلال المتدحرجة خارج ماريوبول في
شرق أوكرانيا
في القسم 21 ، تشير الأعلام
الأوكرانية في مهب الريح إلى قبور
القوات الأوكرانية ، ومعظمهم من الشبان الذين
لقوا حتفهم في القتال ضد القوات المدعومة من روسيا
في السنوات الثماني الماضية وغالبًا ما
تجاهلوا الصراع  قتل ما يصل
إلى أربعة عشر ألف شخص بما في ذلك
أكثر من ثلاثة آلاف مدني ،
كان روسلان بوستوفيت جنديًا الآن
يقاتل مع مجموعة قومية
يمينية تسمى القطاع الصحيح ،
بوتين رجل صغير مثير للشفقة
الجميع مستعد لتمزيق الروس
بأيديهم.  يقول إنه يعرف حوالي 200
شخص قُتلوا ، فقد أظهر لنا
قبر أحدهم ، وهو صديق سقط الآن
محفورًا على الحجر ، بالإضافة إلى ذاكرته ،
فقد مات العديد من الرفاق الكثير من
المدنيين
في فترة القيادة الباردة القارس رومان
بيريزكو  كاهن يصلي عند
قبر صديقه الشاهق وهو من الأوائل
من هنا ليموت في القتال ولكنه
يصلي بهدوء وأنت.  يوجد في nderstated
جانبان يقسمان واجباته
كقسيس في الجيش في ثوبه الأخضر الزيتوني الذي
يقول إنه دعوته ويرعى
جماعة مدنية في كنيسة الماريجوانا الصغيرة هذه
[موسيقى
] نفقد أفضل
أفرادنا ، حيث تمنح الكنيسة الناس الراحة إذا طلبوا ذلك
ما الذي سيحدث بعد
ذلك نقول إنها مشيئة الله نستعد
للأسوأ ونأمل لأفضل
الناس الذين لا يستطيعون الذهاب إلى الكنيسة اطلب من
peretyatko الصلاة من أجلهم يقول
أسمائهم على المذبح بين
حفنة من الذين جاءوا هذا الصباح هو هذا
رجل كان لديه شيء واحد في ذهنه
السلام ،
نحن نصلي من أجل السلام قبل كل شيء الحمد لله ،
إنه سلام الآن نحن نأخذه
يومًا واحدًا في كل مرة ، سنرى ما سيحدث
بعد
ذلك أظهر شعب أوكرانيا
هدوءًا غير عادي في مواجهة  هذا
التهديد الروسي ، لكن من الواضح أنه يتسبب
في خسائر فادحة
، أخبرونا أن نحافظ على هدوئنا ونود
أن نعيش بسلام للذهاب إلى العمل
لتربية الأطفال ، وكان الأحفاد
قلقين كيف لا يمكننا أن نكون
ما إذا كانت هذه القطعة هشة  هذا هو الحال
في هذه المدينة الآن
سؤال حقًا لا يعرف إلا رجل واحد الإجابة
على أليكس ماركوارت سي إن ماريوبول أوكرانيا.